are you proud of what you've done today
no it's not think I'll kick some ass
anymore
angry Evan in my life celebrate the sock
man mark Tigers I struggle with
respecting the efforts results are great
Park is their result I love results - I
love results you need to get results but
where the results come from effort
results come from effort if you just tie
yourself respect to your results then
you will play small for life because
when you first start you don't get
results because it's messy and you suck
so when you go off and you do your first
video you're gonna you're not gonna get
results and people quit because it
didn't get results cuz it didn't get
comments and likes and subscribes and
all that you didn't get it you think
that your results - what that's what
adults do mark wants to join in live all
right let's bring listen what if what if
you get great results it'll blow sorry
sorry this is already sucky ok yes what
if no there's lots of us who get results
with minimal effort and so we learn and
train ourselves to focus on results more
than effort of course dude the whole
world is based on results on effort the
whole world that's why everybody hates
their life so but it's one thing for you
to tell us what we got to do right you
know we have to think of the future we
have to forgive people you know we have
to we have to can't focus on the past
it's one thing for you to say focus on
effort how do we do that ask yourself am
i proud right now today of my effort
like think about whatever you've been
working on today there's Drakkar working
from home on a Friday are you proud of
what you've done today no it's not then
go kick some ass you're not proud of
yourself
great go do something make yourself
proud and in the moment like what do you
need to do to make yourself proud mark
of your effort today I don't know I
gotta make my instant video that's for
sure at the very least great so this is
good are you proud of your effort for
making instant video no I
started to okay but but once you finish
it Arthur than you now proud of your
effort for making a new video no great
so what do you need to do to be proud of
your efforts my kids they're all
gathering around right now
great great this is listen I love it
this is this is proud papa moment what
do you need to do today mark Drager to
make yourself proud of your effort I
need to work harder okay so on what what
are you gonna do I want to do my insta
médio I want to work on my website I
don't know man you helped me great so
then let's make your insta video right
now this is your instant video go oh man
you don't realize I spend an hour
putting together those videos trying to
think of what to say
I do realize mr. perfectionist go know
you're avoiding the issue I want to get
you back on the topic how no this is the
issue now do you know we're doing it
right now we're in the mud this is what
it looks like you do it okay you ask
yourself how would I be proud of my
effort and then you say I need to make
an Instagram video and I need to work on
my website and then the next step is
immediate action so I said let's go make
our Instagram video we're in the mud
we're actually doing it and then we're
gonna come out on the other side and
have you feel proud so let's make sure
it's you can be do right now go mark I
feel like me just waiting to you and
saying hey let's do a livestream so you
can yell at me in front of everyone was
was a good first step are you proud of
that I am actually there's only my
second lime and amazing see that's great
that's a great fight look mark jakers
part of his efforts no I didn't do
anything you joined in yes okay now
let's make mark Drager even more proud
of his effort make your Instagram video
this is it you and me we're making a
video go okay what do you want to talk
about whatever you want to talk about I
don't have a talk about being part of
your effort my book that I kids are
loving watching me sweat right now
perfect why are you sweating why are you
sweating because here's the thing right
so it's one
thing to say these things right it's one
thing to say okay respect the effort
it's not about the results but every day
in every moment and and whatever's
getting thrown at you changes I don't
know what I'm trying to say what I'm
trying to say yeah nobody knows a dude
you're in your own way just make a video
why are you sweating you said I'm
sweating why you sweating oh because I
anyway cuz I don't I don't you're
putting me on the spot this is like when
we were at Tony Robbins and we're
walking to the McDonald's and you're
like great make a video and I'm like and
you're like make a video about leaves
make a video about the sunshine and yeah
great okay spend some more time thinking
about it than that but okay so so make a
video about being put on the spot and
how you want to make yourself proud
great this is a very bad livestream that
everyone's watching right now it's
amazing it's the best it's the best this
is what happens when you respect your
effort and you produce craft results you
grow stronger and you get better what I
like doing is giving amazing results
with very little effort that's where I'm
most go those are not the same thing
what you like doing and what you're most
comfortable doing are not the same thing
no I know
that's all you just said it you do set
it back that's my quick guide that's my
question to you make a video mark let's
go listen guys everybody watch it - I've
known mark for like ten years so if you
guys call it I may not yell at you as
harsh talk about make a video about
being put on the spot
let's go I don't like being put on the
spot I don't like be uncomfortable and I
don't like being bad at things I like
being good at things without even trying
and that is the worst thing why why is
that the worst thing because when I was
younger I was just naturally good at
stuff and I've always been really quick
to pick things up and always good at
stuff and so I trained myself to go
towards things that I'm naturally good
at and I don't like to look stupid
but you knew what was gonna happen dude
you knew what was gonna happen
[Laughter]
I need more angry Evan in my life
great so cut that up and there's your
video perfect perfect look at that you
expected your effort for two things
already in the past 15 minutes yeah no I
still feel like I'm phoning it in I'm
letting you down so I got I got it I
gotta do better
how about letting me down who cares
about me don't let yourself down it's
your effort letting me down as results
yeah I got I got I gotta think that sir
well let's think it through I got
rewarded for crushing it and picking up
things quickly and now you just expect
to pick up everything quickly yeah and
that will mean you'll stay doing small
things that you can pick up quickly yes
but everything everything that you
actually want to do you don't know how
to do and is difficult and is hard yeah
and there's no instruction manual for
and you won't pick up quickly and that's
why you're frustrated with life Wow yeah
how do you pick up being a good father
quickly a good husband quickly I'm
visionary entrepreneur quickly you don't
you suck you fail the beginning is
always messy right so respect your
effort and getting through the mess to
get to the other side is the question
the question then becomes like where
does where does the respect come from
like for me when I think of respecting
it's it's being proud of what you put
into it it's it's dulling as hard and as
far as you can and if you've done
everything that you can and then you
fall in short it's like well at least I
gave it everything that I can okay I do
too much not well enough to have the
time to push everything as far and hard
as I'd like to I'm too busy yeah to give
everybody the time to give everything
the time you've no priorities you
haven't prioritize what you want to do
too busy Jesus Christ never say I don't
have time you control your life mark you
control your calendar yeah but you're
not too busy what I'm saying is I for me
for me to give something
the the amount of effort where if it
still falls short I'm still proud of it
that's all that's a lot of time a lot of
them in a lot of effort no no no you're
already losing okay I still fall [ __ ]
fall short of what you're still looking
for results suck expect to suck at the
beginning you're gonna suck what results
there are no results
you're still goal-oriented and you're
kind of giving lip service to the effort
you just want to win easy no I'm okay
being better things no you're not
sometimes this is going pretty
disastrous you want to be okay with
being bad at things which is why you
called in but you're not actually okay
with being bad at the things you care
about right your one words extraordinary
but it should be extraordinary effort
not extraordinary results and the result
the effort will lead to results the
Africa leads to the results you will if
you keep working hard to something and
get better at it for sure
you just will and then you'll get
results you can do anything you focus on
it's just hi I don't know I got my
thinking I hear what you're saying yes
so I don't understand how to process
thoughts that way the way you're saying
you just you just catch yourself are am
i proud of my effort today no great what
do I need to do you just said I need to
I'm proud of me for getting on with this
thing with Evan I need to make Instagram
video I need to work on my website so
you've got two to the three that go
crush no it's the effort your website
might suck you might go around in
circles and spend five hours and just
stare at a blank thing of Photoshop and
have thrown away 85 drafts of the same
thing but are you part of the effort
like yeah I spent five hours I'm pumped
no you put in the effort it's messy at
the start what are you doing in those
five hours are you getting distracted by
Facebook are you going through your
Instagram dm's are you wasting no you're
working you're hustling you're not
getting the result but if you put in
five more or
more or five more you'll get the result
you're looking for you gotta leave you
gotta leave this with me I got it I got
to rewire my brain we just did did we
that's what you do you ask yourself am i
proud of my effort and for everything
for a father husband parishioner you
know everything are you appreciate I
didn't know what to say that what is
your role in the church mark that's it
mark every day whenever you doubt
yourself you ask yourself am i part of
my effort I didn't get the result
whenever you feel low and depressed that
you didn't win you didn't get your
trophy
you didn't get the results yes I'm part
of the effort good job
what do you want to teach your kids I
only love you when you win I hope I'm
not teaching of that what you're
teaching yourself at thank you because
your kids see how you act and they act
the same way
daddy's only happy when he gets results
I need to get results I need to win I
need to I need to get that trophy so I'm
only gonna do things where I know I'm
gonna get a trophy instead of going to
dance class and sucking my face off
[Laughter]
they're really enjoying watching you
yell at me listen so is everybody watch
[Laughter]
this this is the best parenting lesson
of all time for you here's dad doing
something that he's struggling with and
getting through and respecting his
effort for am i proud of my effort yep
so what do I do today mark to be part of
your effort it's already four o'clock so
know you got your time is winding down
but no the mercury I know can do a lot
of damage in eight hours the mark I know
can change the world in eight hours so
what are you in the next eight hours
mark to respect your effort and when you
sleep you're gonna be like man I crushed
that day
so today I was supposed to start filming
in the studio all of the YouTube videos
reddened and it got away from me
and I had to come pick up my kids okay
courtesy no I think I need to make I
need to make a youtube video
it's the Instagram videos are easy I
need to make a youtube video
great so if you made a video with then
all the phone then I'll overcome today
great and you respect your effort yeah
outside in the freezing cold
Toronto like how are you even Toronto
urine like yeah yeah yeah you're in the
middle of nowhere out in the snow here's
drinker holding this phone out mister
fancy video production agency owner
filming the video off his cell phone
shaking cuz he's so cold that's a video
there you go
are you gonna do that yeah I'll do it I
want to see it but that I will respect
the first video I did I wanted to make
amazing instead I did it at your
Pittsburgh event and it was perfect
let's celebrate that celebrate the sock
man you need to start celebrating the
effort because you would have waited
another week and another week and then
it's months and nothing happens yeah
focus on focus on what mark focus on
effort no well yes but what's on your
board o momentum yeah man momentum you
can see the lesson it's the same thing
it's the same lesson you don't get
momentum by being perfect never ever
yeah ok great so do it
so make your video and post it and never
waiting go follow life and Fanta life a
Fanta and Hounds him if he doesn't post
this video pound him
alright mark oh I gotta get busy man
whenever I sit down with a candidate
during the interview process I tried to
help explain how I look at the team and
how I look at staff for me personally as
an entrepreneur I evaluates staff based
on four criteria the first does the
person fit in with the team do they fit
into the culture you can't have someone
work for your company if they don't fit
into the culture culture is almost
everything but of course it's not
everything so that's why there's four
things second do they do good work is
there quality to the work that they do
are they capable of doing the work are
they capable of executing at your level
can they actually do the work that you
need them to do third can they go about
the work the way that you need them to
everybody has to have processes
everybody has to have certain attention
to details you know in our marketing
firm it comes down to naming convention
the way that we email people it comes
down to work back schedules it comes
down to how we communicate and how do we
post things in our project management
software and what do we do with data
management and backups like everyone has
processes so the third thing is do can
they follow the process can they fit in
and then lastly is do you have value for
money a lot of people don't think about
this is there value for money on my team
once I had someone who was earning a
pretty entry level rate it was a junior
position
the thing is they worked three times as
slow as someone at a senior level so the
junior rate was half of a senior level
but they worked three times as slow
means I'm losing money actually it would
have been better for me to hire a second
senior person and have them work three
times faster and have someone at have to
pay work three times as low and so the
reason I share this with everyone that
I'm interviewing is because I also share
it with everyone on my team as I'm doing
performance reviews as I'm having my
monthly check-in the team the team
members as a manager and as it someone
who you report to you need to understand
the criteria in which that you're being
judged and so for me it's important that
I hit at least three out of those four
things one you have to fit into the
culture but if you're slightly off
culture and have the other three things
you'll get by right you do great work
you go about the work properly and you
have value for money the cultures
slightly off it's gonna be a little bit
bumpy but that's still a good person now
let's say that you fit in the culture
but the quality of work is in there but
you go about it really well and you
value for money well you can be trained
can you not can you not get better can
you not train the person can you not
help them get better at their role can
you not try and work to make sure that
the quality is better of course you can
so you have three out of the four if
you're missing the third thing which is
process well that's a little bit tough
right they fit into the culture they do
amazing work in this value for money but
they don't follow the process that can
be frustrating too there's no doubt
about it if someone won't follow the
process but if the person is really that
good at the work and they fit in the
culture and there's value for money
you're probably gonna do things to
isolate them in such a way to alleviate
the the fact that they don't follow the
process maybe you'll hire them assistant
maybe you'll make certain exceptions for
not following the process maybe there's
such a genius and they're so good at
their job that you're gonna actually
just pluck them out from what they're
doing and create kind of like this
little island in the team amongst
themselves because they're that good and
then the last thing is let's say that
they fit in the culture they do great
work they go about the work properly but
there's no real value for money well if
you can afford to keep them around
you're going to write as a manager of
course you're going to they fit in the
culture they do great work like ideally
you're gonna have all four right you
want someone who has the culture you
want someone who does amazing work at
your expectations are even higher you
want someone who can you can work with
who you like who follows the process who
can communicate who can do all of those
things you need them to do and then you
need value for money ideally you need
all four but in my experience you're not
gonna find all four right you're gonna
find someone who has three out of the
four and then you're gonna coach them to
all four if they don't have three out of
four that's gonna be tough it's really
gonna be tough you're gonna have to
consider letting that person go just
think of it they don't fit in the
culture and there's no value for money
okay so great so they do great work and
they can go about the process properly
but if they don't fit the culture no one
likes them and if there's no value for
money then that doesn't work right or
what about
they they do great quality work and
there's value for money but they can't
they're sloppy about how they go about
it they can't follow a process at all
and they're not in the culture so no one
likes them we don't have that person
around either so I lay this all out in
the interview process because I want
people to understand that they have to
tell me how they're gonna fit into these
boxes right I try to make it as clear as
possible you tell me what you're gonna
do to fit into this process so those
points again not to harp on it too long
for simple simple things do they fit
into the culture do they have quality in
their work and can they hit the level
that you're looking for do they go about
the work in the way that you need them
to and do you have value for money tell
me what you think tell me about how you
hire people and how you evaluate your
team or if you're working for someone
ask them how they evaluate you let me
know what you think of the four things I
hope it helps and as always remember to
think big be bold and say yes if you
want more of me and mark Drager check
out the how to build a million-dollar
marketing agency series I did with him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there